the new covet variant is yet another
hurdle in an otherwise decidedly busy
time in washington the senate set to
return tomorrow the house on tuesday
lawmakers have just a few days to avert
a government shutdown and a little more
than two weeks to raise the limit on
borrowing or default for the first time
in the nation's history while democrats
face their own self-imposed year-end
deadline to pass the president's
build-back better plan with likely no
republican support with us now from
wyoming the number three republican in
the senate john barrasso he is a senator
welcome back to fox news sunday sir
we've got a lot of politics to talk
about as we said you know you're going
back to work tomorrow the house comes
back on tuesday but very quickly a lot
of breaking news on this omicron variant
you're a medical doctor as well
senator barrasso give us your quick take
are you concerned about this new variant
coming possibly maybe already here in
the united states
well you know as a doctor i am
pro-vaccine and i'm anti-the mandate
vaccines work we have a new variant
there's going to continue to be new
variants in the future
medicines are better now than they have
been but i think the president was wrong
with his mandate i think it was a
monumental overreach and i think it's
actually hardened people against the
vaccine and the president has divided
the country because of the mandate now
you have a couple of governors saying oh
two shots isn't enough now you have to
have three the things that are
interesting about this the last guest
just talked about
the inflation that we have we have 10
million job openings in this country and
yet the president with his mandate wants
to fire people who have been going to
work every day
since the pandemic started people who
may not want to get the vaccine police
officers firefighters nurses border
patrol so that's one part of it the
other is joe biden ran for office
basically hiding in his basement saying
he could protect america from covid well
he didn't he can't and more people have
died of covid
under president biden than did in all of
2020. and we are going to talk about
that coming up at the panel meantime the
build back better bill you got a lot of
stuff going on this week up on the hill
senator what's the status of that where
do you think it's going is it is it now
time to inject trillions of dollars back
into the economy
no we have record inflation right now i
i view this as a back-breaking bill for
the country with the kind of expenses
the spending the adding to the debt the
inflation the taxes that are going to
hit the american people
and you know for joe biden to say we
have to spend even more money on top of
inflation to me this is
alice in wonderland logic he's the mad
hatter out here he continues to try to
mislead the american people first saying
the cost will be zero zero zero when the
budget analysts have said it's going to
be hundreds of billions of dollars added
to the debt people's taxes are going to
go up he said oh no only if you make
over four hundred thousand a year that's
not what the tax
experts are telling us they say one out
of three middle class americans will pay
more in taxes so on all of these issues
and inflation across the board people
saying we're looking at persistent
inflation we cannot ignore inflation
that is the thing that's going to hurt
our economy the most you talk about
republicans they're against the build
back better thing they're also against
raising the debt limit mitch mcconnell
said it would just enable democratic
spending but the wall street journal
says and i'm quoting here sir vote to
raise the debt limit doesn't authorize
new spending but it's essentially it
allows the the treasury to raise money
to pay for expenses the government has
already authorized so this is to pay for
things already authorized and it's
important to point out in your state
alone
this is paying for things like almost
thirty thousand people getting snack
snap benefits of course that's food
benefits thirty three thousand students
eligible for free or reduced school
lunches so a lot of benefits from this
to your state senator why are you
against it
well in my state i was a member of the
state senate our constitution demands
that we balance our budget every year
that we live within our means just like
families all across america need to do
and i think the federal government ought
to do the same thing this is all about
democrat spending this is a hundred
percent on them if you get rid of
all of the gimmicks
of accounting this bill that the
democrats are proposing
is four trillion dollars in additional
spending there's not a single republican
who's going to vote for the bill or to
raise the debt ceiling this is on the
democrats
you know you're also the ranking member
of the energy committee and i want to
put this up on the thing the food gas
electricity prices we've seen this and
we talked about this with dr l aryan you
know the fact that food is up gas is up
49.6
electricity 6.5 we're not even at the
coldest part of the winter senator it's
going to get bad for a lot of families
it's going to get very expensive you
have the president putting 50 million
barrels of oil from the reserves back on
the market maybe hit the market sometime
mid-december but on the other hand the
president is also making it more
expensive to drill on federal lands sir
how do you how do you square the two
it can't be squared the president isn't
able to do this
look today is one of the busiest travel
days in america and as people are
hitting the road
gas prices are hitting the roof
day one in the in the white house the
president drew a target on the back of
american energy pulled the trigger and
now with this strategic petroleum
reserve what he's doing is basically
trying to put a little band-aid on that
bullet hole the strategic petroleum
reserve is there for emergencies
national emergencies war not to cover
over bad policies the amount that he's
releasing is equal to what we use in
this country in just two and a half days
and today in america we're using more
oil
from russia from vladimir putin's russia
than we are from alaska this is a
jackpot for vladimir putin and what the
we have this oil in the ground the
president and the environmental movement
will not let us use american oil so
president biden is going had in hand to
opec and to russia saying please produce
more oil so we can buy it from you this
is a disaster it's a major policy
mistake we need to be using american
energy and you get to work back on
capitol hill this week sir what's the
remedy from from the republicans what's
the remedy for this if the president's
leads here if the president's moves are
not the elixir what is it what do we do
to get gas prices down what do we do to
get energy prices down and stabilize
before we move into winter
yes we use american energy we stop the
bans that this administration has on
energy you know senator manchin who's
the ranking member of the who's the
chairman of the energy committee in
which i'm the rank member said let's get
the keystone pipeline going there's lots
we have the resources here we are much
stronger as a nation if we are selling
energy to our friends then if we have to
buy it from our enemies look i just got
back from the persian gulf
spent thanksgiving there with the
wyoming troops and talking to military
leaders
after what happened in afghanistan in
the disaster of the withdrawal our
enemies are much more aggressive and to
be giving a jackpot of additional money
to vladimir putin is really in the
long-term detriment of the united states
you talk about the persian gulf what are
they saying about the american energy
policies i mean you know the president
has gone to opec saying hey we need to
open the spigots a little bit and get
some more oil on the market what are
they saying i mean they've been they've
been hesitant to do that what's the word
over there is there this belief that
maybe the united states should be doing
more to help itself
well we ought to be doing more to help
ourselves it's incumbent upon us to do
that there are ways that we
we can protect the environment without
punishing the economy i don't know that
the
democrats understand that major concept
but what i saw in the persian gulf was a
much more aggressive iran
also we're seeing it with communist
china we're seeing with vladimir putin
we're seeing it with north korea and you
talked about all the things that we
haven't done yet in congress this
national defense authorization act this
should have been passed months ago but
it's been on the back burner for joe
biden and for for chuck schumer we never
want to send our men and women in
uniform into a fair fight we want to
make sure that they have strength can
project strength we want to make sure
they have the equipment the manpower the
firepower that they need and this
administration not just as wrong on
energy they have been very weak this
president has been weak on national
defense because when he came into office
his first budget basically supersized
government on everything except for two
areas where we didn't even keep up with
inflation one was defense the other was
homeland security our nation deserves
better you you make a very good point in
the national defense authorization act
because now you have you know russian
troops amassing at the ukrainian border
you have china with threatening language
toward taiwan and yet the window is
narrowing to get this done i mean it's
been passed 60 years in a row we're
assuming that that you know congress
will move heaven and earth to get it
passed but the window is narrowing how
do you get this thing done quickly
you're right the window is now on
because we have that the government runs
out of money this friday we have the
debt ceiling as you mentioned and
joe biden and chuck schumer want to pass
this massive tax and spending bill
by
christmas
we have
an entire republican conference who
wants to do everything we can to defeat
it i think the best christmas present
for the american people would be to
block these increased taxes block this
bill that causes more inflation and the
more people know what's in this bill
the worse it becomes because people
really don't like so many of the things
that are in this bill which is going to
raise taxes and increase inflation
senator john barrasso dr barrasso thank
you for joining us this morning we
appreciate it
thank you trace